From being
the B in apartment 23
to the super-strong
Jessica Jones,
Krysten Ritter is a delight
whatever show
or movie she's cast in.
And now we get to see her
try her hand
at playing an evil witch
in Netflix's Nightbooks.
Boo.
But first, let's pay tribute
to her incredible
career so far
and take a look
at her road to Netflix.
Back to the 2000s
and to the start
of Krysten's budding
acting career.
Here she is
in a 2002 Fiat advert.
Then a model
signed to Wilhelmina.
No big deal.
She dazzled
casting directors
with her bubbly personality,
which made her transition
from modelling to acting
a natural fit.
Her early roles were
bit parts in film and TV,
such as the role of one
of the art history students
in Mona Lisa Smile.
"Funeral Mask,"
Mycenaean, 1200.
By 2005,
Krysten was popping up
as a recurring character
on long-running shows.
From 2005 to 2006,
she played Gia Goodman
on the murder mystery
teen drama Veronica Mars.
Her character
was the daughter
of a wealthy
baseball team owner,
attending Neptune High
alongside
Kristen Bell's Veronica.
She reprised this role
in the 2014 film,
where Gia returns,
now a wealthy socialite
in the frame for murder.
So many mixed emotions
right now.
I kind of hated you, like
a lot, but I don't anymore.
Just trying
to remember my progress,
because blaming you
for telling the whole world
that my dad was a paedophile
is what my therapist calls
"misplaced aggression."
So, basically,
we're totally cool.
Following her original stint
on Veronica Mars,
she appeared on another
hugely beloved show,
Gilmore Girls.
-Is that too much popcorn?
-Uh, yeah.
I'm really hungry.
Between 2006 and 2007,
she played one of Rory's
classmates at Yale, Lucy.
From 2008 to 2010,
she cropped up in some
classic romantic comedies,
from playing the goth bride
in 27 Dresses,
to the best friend in
Confessions of a Shopaholic,
and She's Out of my League.
Kirk, Molly's into you.
And here's one
you'll remember
if you're a big fan
of Gossip Girl.
In 2009, there were plans
for a potential spinoff
prequel series
about a young
Lily van der Woodsen's life
in the 1980s.
An episode in the second
series of Gossip Girl
served as a backdoor pilot,
with Krysten playing Lily's
rebellious older sister,
Carol Rhodes.
Come on, it's us.
We travel in style,
no matter how we travel.
Arguably, her breakout role
was as Jane Margolis
in Breaking Bad.
Because what
I know about you,
high-school teacher
turned drug dealer
with a brother-in-law
in the DEA,
that would make
one hell of a story.
National news, I'll bet.
Do right by Jesse tonight,
or I will burn you
to the ground.
Jane was Jesse's neighbour
and eventual girlfriend,
struggling
with drug addiction.
Thanks to Walt, Jane dies
a pretty horrible death,
which had
major repercussions
on Jesse's character
throughout the rest
of the series.
This was Krysten's
meatiest role to date
and cemented her acting
chops outside of comedy.
Having starred in her
fair share of romcoms,
Krysten decided
to write her own in 2011.
Life Happens starred Krysten
in the main role of Kim,
a woman who gets pregnant
after a one-night stand
and becomes
a single mother still living
with her two roommates.
Nobody tells you
it's going to be so hard.
Yes, they do, Kim.
That's pretty much
all people say.
In an interview, she said
she and director Kat Coiro
came up with the plot
after Kat had a baby.
Staying with comedy, but
with a dash of camp horror,
we've got 2012's Vamps,
in which Krysten starred
alongside Alicia Silverstone
as two vampires trying
to stay youthful and trendy.
Krysten's character, Stacy,
gets herself into a pickle
when she finds herself
accidentally dating the son
of none other than legendary
vampire hunter Van Helsing.
-He's goofy but cute.
-What's his name?
His name is Joey…
Van Helsing.
What?
Don't Trust the B----
in Apartment 23
saw Krysten play wild
New York party girl Chloe,
next to Dreama Walker's
idealistic June,
in an odd couple sitcom
about an unlikely
friendship.
Fun fact, Dawson Creek's
James van der Beek
also starred in the show
as a fictionalised
version of himself.
I'm gonna send this.
-To who?
-Everyone.
Krysten's Chloe
was the perfect vehicle
for her comedic talents,
a character who was lovable
despite being
completely irresponsible.
While the show was cancelled
after two seasons,
it proved popular with fans,
who have even
set up petitions
for it to be renewed,
and was nominated for
a few Teen Choice Awards.
On to 2014, and Krysten had
a whole host of movie roles.
But her biggest film
that year
was Tim Burton's Big Eyes.
It dramatizes the life
of American artist
Margaret Keane,
whose famed paintings
of characters with big eyes
were initially attributed
to her husband.
Playing the outspoken Diane,
Krysten fulfilled her goal
of working on a Tim Burton
movie with this role,
telling Nylon it was
"a total dream come true."
Strange, you know,
Walter doesn't
really strike me
as a cute,
hungry kitten type.
And in 2015,
we got to see Krysten on
Netflix for the first time
as the incomparable
Jessica Jones.
In this role, her star power
was fully realised
as the conflicted,
hard-drinking and, well,
hard-hitting
former superhero.
Starring alongside
David Tennant's
terrifying Kilgrave,
Krysten got rave reviews
for her work
on the Marvel series,
which explored themes like
sexual assault and PTSD.
Come back here!
Whoa.
She also directed an episode
in the final series
of the show.
In 2017, she starred
in The Defenders,
where Jessica Jones teams up
with Luke Cage,
Iron Fist and Daredevil.
Bullet-proof. Blind ninja.
-Whatever it is you are.
-Classy.
Another Netflix role
she reprised
was that of Jane
from Breaking Bad,
in a surprise
flashback cameo
at the end of 2019's
El Camino.
I've gone where the universe
takes me my whole life.
It's better to make those
decisions for yourself.
That brings us to 2021
and Krysten's latest
Netflix project, Nightbooks.
This time she gets to play
a villain as a witch
who takes a young boy
named Alex prisoner.
In order to save his life,
he convinces her
to let him write a scary
story for her each night.
Did you say…
scary stories?
But at the same time,
he teams up with
another prisoner to try
and figure out a way
to escape her clutches.
This will hurt you far more
than it hurts me.
Make sure
you don't miss Nightbooks,
now streaming on Netflix.
And for more
on your favourite
actress trajectories
to Netflix
and the stories behind your
favourite shows and movies,
make sure you subscribe
to the channel.
What is that?
Read.
Now.